las protestas en belarús continúan
contra alexander lukashenko los obreros
de las principales fábricas del país
acataron el llamado de huelga de la
oposición después de que denunciase
fraude en las elecciones del 9 de agosto
y que la principal candidata a sustituir
a lukashenko se haya visto obligada a
marcharse a lituania a pesar de no estar
ya en el país es vendrán ática no pesca
ya se ve capacitada para liderar una
transición estoy preparada para asumir
la responsabilidad y actuar como líder
de la nación durante este período para
que el país se tranquilice y vuelva a la
normalidad para que podamos liberar a
todos los presos políticos y preparar el
marco legal y las condiciones para
realizar otra ronda de elecciones
presidenciales en el menor tiempo
posible elecciones genuinas justas y
transparentes que serán aceptadas por la
comunidad internacional
desde los comicios las protestas han
sacudido todo el país y se han
convertido en las mayores de la historia
belarús está bajo el poder indiscutible
de lukashenko desde 1994 y su respuesta
a la oposición han sido duras cargas
policiales la unión europea ya acordó
sanciones contra el país por la
situación política y este miércoles
reunirá al consejo europeo convocará una
reunión de los miembros del consejo
europeo este miércoles al mediodía para
discutir la situación en belarús el
pueblo de belarús tiene derecho a
decidir sobre su futuro y elegir
libremente a su líder la violencia
contra los manifestantes es inaceptable
y no se puede permitir a pesar de la
presión interna y externa lukashenko
sigue negando la posibilidad de repetir
elecciones y ceder ante la calle aunque
ha hablado de posibles reformas
constitucionales que redistribuyan el
poder